now it's time for the 80 for Brady's
starting lineup
Lily Tomlin Wayne State University Rita
Moreno P.S 132 Sally Field Birmingham
High School Jane Fonda College Dropout
the 80 for Brady trailer starts in three
two one
game's about to start oh there's Tom Oh
What a Beautiful I like Gronkowski we
know Chris we've all read your grunk
erotica it's not erotica it's fan
fiction very sexy fan fiction
aren't you tired of the same old boring
lives let's go to the Super Bowl the
Super Bowl is no place for four old
women this could be Tom's last one he's
almost 40. that's like 80 in people
years yeah we're 80 in people years I
just really need this trip
[Music]
I can't believe we're actually here
taking this one he's cute so you don't
have any tickets how much for four ten
thousand ten thousand well I have a 20
in my strap-on that's a fanny pack if
you work like this it's a strap-on wow
it is so great to meet your beauty has
no expiration dates Chris I didn't flirt
he did there's so much here to do we
could even win these tickets this is a
spicy wings contest I could use a little
spice I know her if you blackout who you
want me to call an ambulance oh if you
did this you give us something to
remember why honey didn't work do you
think you could get us in follow me
these are my dancers prove it what the
answer you ladies know the twist a jerk
let's do it
[Music]
thank you
isn't that what friendship is that we
Face the unknown together let's go
Golden Girls come with me
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go oh my God
rain
these are good very good oh careful
they're high dosage high dosage
because me I'm looking for someone are
you okay
I'm Guy Fieri
the original fairy tales are all the
same
the princess the hero but this story
about me meow
our next Target is this way okay what
have you noticed there's no food that is
odd for a market Town
it smells doesn't it smells like a a
mystery
the food
continues to disappear
us you wanted to see us there are new
rats in town I can feel catch them and
bring them to me yeah yes sir remember
this is a new town There's bound to be
new tracks oh God I know just what we
must do next to solve the mystery of our
town ready
your savior has arrived hey
everyone look for the entrance to the
secret passage
Keith are you all right yeah I'm all
right because I landed on my head no
wonder we didn't see it
know I have a thing for rats it's not
cool to pick on the little guy fighting
for our life you can't find me police
follow me here I come
come to me
then feel my pain
if my head fits the rest will follow
the amazing Maurice it's really not your
average fairy tale don't worry I can't
always lands on its feet
[Music]
amazing Maurice
hi there
can I talk to you for a little bit
you should come inside right now there
were four of them what did we say you
shouldn't make things up when we're
talking about
can you open the door please
we're not here to hurt you but you have
to stay here in the cabin with us
families throughout history have been
chosen to make this decision your family
must choose to willingly sacrifice one
of the three of you to prevent the
apocalypse we're not sacrificing anyone
for every no you give us
hundreds of thousands of people are
going to die
[Music]
close your eyes
will you make a choice
you have to somehow trust us we're
normal people just like you it doesn't
matter none of us believe you
we will never choose anyone
where
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm afraid the rule is that no one's
allowed to leave until you choose
do you really think it's all just a
coincidence I have to believe that my
son is gonna die his name is Charlie as
a mother I am begging you to apparently
anyone who can stop this Andrew I saw
something there was something in the
light
I feel it now
my family
I fail to choose a world will perish
we've been given the chance to decide
the fate of everyone Conjuring out of
the world I'm scared
there's nothing more flawed and perfect
in this world than our family believe my
good choice
together oh together
I will ask for the last time will you
make a choice
[Music]
what did you want before Miami
I just wanted to escape my life
I need you
do you like bartending it's not really
what I do what is it that you really
don't
know
you came along and gave me these
unexpected
magical moment
that made me remember who I really was
[Music]
come with me to London
let's go
why are you in London I'm gonna put on a
show at this famous theater
[Music]
disconnected we're gonna wake them up
with a wave of passion they've never
felt before
hell yeah without further Ado I give you
the Visionary artist magic mine
so
the real question is why do you love her
no one's believed in me like a mom has
so what's the show about it's the same
more will she marry For Love or Money so
what does she pick
Ed the real question is why does she
feel like she has to choose it sounds to
me she just needs to let go
[Music]
and some good
maybe that as well
[Music]
you're not shutting me down not this
time you're so good at this I'm not
gonna just let us give up on it I want
every woman that walks into this theater
to feel that a woman can have whatever
she wants whatever she wants there's
[Music]
wait I know you you were a cop right did
you arrest her what's your name Kim
let you out for the warning right
listen I've got you I Won't Let Go
[Music]
Titanic was called the ship of Dreams
it was
really was
[Music]
give me your hand
trust me
I trust you
open your eyes
I'm flying Jack
[Music]
you never know what hand you're gonna
get dealt next
you'll learn to take life as it comes at
you
[Music]
to make each day count
I'll Never Let Go Jack
I'll never let go
[Music]
hey Debbie happy birthday 20 years of
friendship can you believe it how do you
still speak to me do you remember the
first night we met
never stops being weird it's so weird
you need to take a break I just need to
just what you have to be when you're a
single mom right right
tragic
I got an idea I'm coming to La for a
week I'm gonna look after Jack and you
can stay here I don't know you need help
let me help taking care of Jack is a lot
of work I think I got this I hope that
you get what you want out of this trip
find yourself a hottie maybe get waxed
waxed oh waxed waxed oh well that's just
not gonna happen
this place is amazing hi I'm Debbie the
Debbie hater talks about you all the
time I am a coach embarrassed I'm not
wearing anything under this oh don't
worry about it we've all done the thing
where we knock on the door half naked
for some
my mom always says you're terrible with
women yeah she does huh so what happens
next can we stay on message you always
answer a question to a question what's a
question
so how's your love life now sort of like
an old ghost town he's yummy wait where
are you going I have no idea what to say
to this guy can I get your number
oh my God
here
he is into you
you and I tell each other everything
right always I think I may have met
someone
can I tell you something immediately the
night that Debbie and I expect together
after I found myself thinking about her
you have to tell her it's too late
[Music]
seriously these are words
wait what is all this Peter's not
interested in me like that is he
I feel like we should see what you and I
could be
this is a minor setback right I
chances
so what are you gonna do
[Music]
Ally
Sean oh my God what are you doing here
you know why I'm just visiting my old
haunts on the off chance I might run
into an X from 10 years ago how many of
you running two so far
[Music]
let's go think about what would have
happened if you hadn't left all those
years ago I've been kind of wondering
the same thing recently
maybe I made her
major I haven't felt that free in
I don't even know how long Sean honey
Mom hey I
agree Jojo
hey what a wonderful thing for us all to
be here so thank you to the bride and
groom for giving us a reason to
celebrate to Sean and Cassidy
I need to see this through whatever it
is you mean like with you in the groom
I mean we can just call him Sean
hey if you're still here if my being
here is making you uncomfortable no no
it wouldn't be very cool of me to kick
out one of Sean's oldest friends
[Music]
[Applause]
oh she was cool she actually reminds me
a lot of me at that age
were he like a nudist I was I have an
idea
[Applause]
keep your eyes on the iPad Bradley pit
Campbell do not taste the naked ladies
gone way too far I don't know I don't
know what to do anymore
[Music]
I'm afraid I've got some bad news
I'm here from the Vatican because of my
brother's bath
I've come to bring the transparency to
this tragedy
before he fell into darkness he was much
loved by everyone fell into darkness
you saw my brother kill himself The Eyes
Of God are on us all
this was the ultimate confessional the
nuts they stand here and for every sin
committed they take a step back the more
steps they took they fell to their death
God caught them
we live a discipline I mean
cleansed purified
[Music]
where are my clothes mother says we must
first remove the filth from them
science what is it you seek
my brother was badly hurt before he fell
I think he discovered something that he
was afraid of
you need help child
something for you
you came in search of Truth
I come here when I have dark thoughts
I think I might be a really bad person
[Music]
what is it that you think you know
don't be scared
there's got one God
foreign
[Music]
you're an interesting man
Scotland
[Applause]
you're an Avenger
[Music]
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time
like me
we could help each other with that
who are you
I'm the man who can give you the one
thing you want
what's that
time
[Music]
I can rewrite existence
and shatter timelines
you cannot trust him I don't care who
this guy is I just lost so much
he can give us a second chance
[Music]
let me make this easy for you
he will bring me what I need
or everything you call a life will end
may not want her to watch this we had a
deal
you thought you could win
I don't have to win
we both just have to lose
I'm sorry Cassie
[Music]
foreign
-blowing people connect Jesus you're
like 11 19 in like three weeks are you
jaded yet
he cheated shut up
I feel like my sister is that there yeah
no but we're more like really good
friends yeah I thought his type Knights
are good boys I was with Cole Cole is
not boys I know she can be like a mess
but I don't really have any other
friends you gotta play off the dramatic
Diner is this actually a dance costume
spawning some serious cleavage
that's always so my extra stuff
ux is gonna kill me oh chill
he won
what's going on that's am I going away
dinner when are you falling do you are
South America come on
[Music]
probably just want to get to bed he
doesn't even drive
can I come
[Music]
walking to your door
promise me I'll meet someone
[Music]
he's a beautiful boy
what are the odds we'll both be arriving
right now I'm a bitter old man he's like
shut up
foreign
[Music]
to this one feeling
sir the police are here please
detective can we talk about this
I'm going to pay you for your time
stop he's not a cop this is what my son
does he plays these games all that work
for one thousand dollars
if you're gonna steal
a lot
what are you doing here just wanted to
say hi I had a good time all right cool
see you around dad
I always assumed my son would inherit
all this he doesn't have the fortitude
he's weak
[Music]
you like him a little bit
of course they like him he's a
billionaire
we're celebrating what exactly are we
celebrating billions of dollars
roll up your sleeves trust me
you can't cheat an honest man
that's why we never feel sorry for the
mark I really like you I really like you
too
you lied to me
human
just to bring the best we can you cause
your mother anguish and I will not have
it she wants me God
how do you think it stands
not well
[Music]
what did you tell him I'm gonna take a
billion dollars and aim it in your
direction
let's go
[Music]
through
this is real
[Music]
Emily
how did you write Wuthering Heights
Shall We Begin
miss Emily Bronte you're off to become a
wonderful teacher you know I don't like
to meet new people
[Music]
what do you want to do do you think I
could be a writer
I have lots of stories
Mr waiting will be tutoring you in
French
he speaks with such poetry
anyone can speak what I want to know is
can he actually do do what
supposed to be an artist so be an artist
what is that I wrote it
freedom and thought freedom and thought
come on
I've often struggled
[Music]
your poetry
not bring shame on this house Emily
did you write these it's an ugly book
there's something ungodly in your
writing I feel it when we're together
do not may call you the strange one
everyone's strange if you look at them
for long enough
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh Jesus
what is that
foreign
worth of cocaine fell from the sky this
morning in Knoxville Tennessee there's
more this out there they dumped it
somewhere I'm looking for my daughter's
Forest is a dangerous place
take it out
[Music]
no don't eat that don't eat that let's
see what kind of effect that has
[Music]
the bear it did cocaine
a bear it was
hey that's inappropriate
you're safe Bears can't climb trees of
course they can
baby
oh
[Music]
it kind of seems like the thing that
stays with the man forever
apex predator
hi on cocaine
I thought of his mind
oh man you what the is wrong
with that bear baby
and don't ever come down
ah
we have such good luck in nature
Samuel Sam come closer
turn around
what I want to take a look at you
Sarah's gonna need your help I have to
sort out Ruth's trust in England she's
your mother so you're gonna have look
after her whether you like it or not the
main thing is her leg I just need your
help with moving her really keeping her
company believe me this is far more
remediating for me than it is for you
gentle here water to here and a squeeze
so how much does an alcoholic drink
anyway two cases in two weeks oh that's
impressed
yes don't ever water it down
do you like another shot seems I have
run out of ammunition come to
[Music]
me I'm surprised you've sent her a way
to boarding school you always said it
ruined your life it keeps him out of
trouble
did you come here
I'd have some small talk first you have
a broken leg and you and Dad hate each
other no I don't hate him
[Music]
he's really there the front lines
is fun I think we should have a party oh
I guess the word got around you sound
like my kind of people
what do you want one more passionate
love of here
[Music]
I'd never have allowed her into our
lives she'll go back eventually
be ashamed
[Music]
most people like sunsets
I love the sunrise
[Music]
again
my dad used to always say there are two
kinds of people in the world Cameron
astronomers and astronauts
some look at the stars others swim in
them
you look like a younger better looking
version of me if you don't believe me
then it's a really crazy story Kim
Tony did you give the Saturday morning
slide to another show they want a
different host Kent Armstrong I I can't
believe you crashed your car yesterday
I'm afraid I have no idea what you're
talking about
it's like my antithesis
some old ass Russian rocket fell from
outer space and it crashed in our
backyard
welcome to Fairview Heights I think this
is just chance all this happening right
now
you're a scientist what else would it be
can I see it sure come on you've got
this pile of Rocket crap right here why
don't you just build your own racket
it's not that simple
yeah it might be
[Music]
remember when we say talk about doing
something fantastic
whatever happened to that I'm the only
one who's even remotely rational anymore
oh you built this thing in like a month
yeah I'm about to do a test to the
booster you want to check it out three
two one
[Music]
what what
Einstein came up with a theory of
relativity when I was 26. if you go do
what you're destined for it's not that
simple it's not that simple not that
simple why do you always tell yourself
that
[Music]
what are you doing something fantastic
now
open your eyes
we're all here
trying to get a fresh start nothing like
bad happened here
right
you moved into the house of death
everyone says it's haunted
don't go
we have a ghost okay no I'm serious
Kevin caught him on camera oh we gotta
show them off no no no no
whoa
the entire world is captivated with
Earnest three million views in six
minutes that's money our whole Street's
kind of mad thanks to you guys Jesus
Christ
not funny
so trippy talk
[Music]
you don't remember mystery
if we're gonna find out what happened
it's out there
our orders
should apprehend the ghost light them up
being an outlaw Suits You
where's Ernest
so Frank is he here now ready to have
some fun